Jimmy because Jimmy's trash I know
somebody wouldn't wanna play against
it's Kevin Durant so I'll tell you that
probably Jason if anything I already
catch this II don't wanna win that
doesn't really show much the basketball
is a team sport and that's that I'll
play anybody who ever wants to play I
think that'd be a great advantage so
whoever wants to play that so I'd be
ready to face I think it'd be fun if
they're gonna all start of one-on-one
competition you know who would I want to
face anybody everybody everybody Chris
Paul cuz I beat him every day in
practice you gotta go for like greats
you want to play against like I read you
know stuff miles fry up against my
teammate wanting a feel for defense I
would say
why
[Music]
I want to see CJ Kevin Durant James I
think that'd be a great time I don't
wanna play Spencer I won Iowa so just
buy you the best one-on-one player out
here man
I said it because he can guard Jimmy
brother he can done Jimmy because
Jimmy's trash
everybody advance that they want you
that's okay no difference they want me I
ain't worried about it